My name, Ndidi, means patience in Igbo.
But I'm probably one of the most impatient
people you've ever met.
I was in such a rush to enter the world
that I was born in the parking lot
of the University of Nigeria
Teaching Hospital.
True story.
Agriculture was my favorite
subject in school.
My mom remembers me squealing for joy
when I ran home from school
and saw green beans ready for harvesting.
Or when I sold a bag of avocados
in our local market.
I considered studying
agriculture in school,
but instead opted to study business
and started in corporate America.
But many twists and turns
led me back to my first love:
consulting, working with entrepreneurs
and then starting businesses.
A defining moment for me was in 2007,
during the first world food crisis
in my adult life.
I recognized how connected we were.
Oil price shocks
led to cereal price hikes,
which affected bread prices
all over the world.
And the most vulnerable were hurt.
Fourteen years later,
my impatience has grown.
We’re even more connected,
and our food ecosystem
is even more broken.
Thankfully, the Rockefeller Foundation
has some pioneering research
on the true cost of food
in the United States,
which indicates that even though
we spend 1.1 trillion
on our annual food expenditure,
we actually spend 2.1 trillion
on costs linked to health
and climate,
all because of our broken food ecosystem.
These same statistics have been
replicated all over the world.
In fact, according to the UN
Food Systems Scientific Group,
our food system is value-destroying.
There's a need for urgent action.
From at least three lenses.
A health lens,
an equity lens and a climate lens.
Starting with the climate lens,
we must modify how we grow food
and reduce food waste.
Our food ecosystem is one of the largest
contributors to climate change.
We keep cutting down trees
to grow more food,
and we keep wasting food
which ends up in landfills and rots,
generates methane.
The good news is
that we have the technology
and the science today
to grow enough food to feed the world
and to address our food waste problems.
We have the knowledge,
but we're not using it.
There are exciting examples
from my ecosystem
where we're seeing dramatic impact.
The Songhai Center in Benin Republic
educates young Africans
on regenerative agriculture
and zero-waste total production.
And one of these young people
is doing just that.
Through his company, Bioloop,
he's feeding waste,
cassava peels, yam peels,
to black soldier fly larva.
They're growing really quickly
and becoming wonderful fish feed.
The byproducts and the residue
from this process
is wonderful soil supplements.
And the entire production process
is run on renewable energy.
Through my work with Sahel Consulting,
we're demonstrating that farmers
can double and triple yields
without hurting the environment.
We're using technology and science
from our local research institutions,
and we're proving that in Africa,
there are great examples
for the rest of the world to emulate.
Now we need to scale these interventions.
And we need to ensure
that our governments,
our private sector, our farmers,
are incentivized to change behavior
and to improve lives.
If you're as impatient as I am,
you also have a role to play,
by reducing the food waste in your home.
Every single person here
can take up a policy
to ensure that their schools,
their companies,
their civil society groups
have a sustainability policy
and a food waste policy.
And please don't tell your children
to finish their dinner
because there are hungry
children anywhere.
Tell them to finish their dinner
because it’s good for the environment,
and healthy food is good for them.
(Applause)
Second, we must ensure
that healthy food is affordable
and accessible for the most vulnerable.
This is a huge challenge.
Unhealthy food kills.
And we know this.
One out of every five deaths
is linked to unhealthy food.
And yet, one third
of our world's population
cannot afford a healthy diet.
This is a big challenge.
Now food is medicine.
Healthy food gives us long
and productive lives.
And during COVID,
we've seen the impact of closures,
shipping challenges
that have affected food prices,
and the most vulnerable have had to shift
from healthy diets to unhealthy diets
because they are cheaper.
This has caused more damage
to lives all over the world.
We must take a stand on this,
and we can learn a lot from Africa.
There Hadzabe people in Tanzania
live in harmony with the land,
and through their lives,
we’ve seen the ability
to have a healthy diet.
They eat ten times more fiber
than the average American.
Oftentimes we don't realize that even
in our own traditional communities,
we have so much to learn.
In urban communities,
we also have exciting
social enterprises like mDoc
that's using digital technology,
cell phones and training
to get urban populations
that are struggling with diabetes,
high blood pressure and so many
other health challenges
linked to eating ultra-processed food
to shift to more traditional diets,
and they’re seeing measurable outcomes.
We must scale these type of interventions,
but we must also hold our private sector
companies responsible
for the amount of sugar
and salt contained in food.
We must set standards
for what healthy food is
and define healthy food
according to plant-based diet,
low salt, low sugar,
and keep all of us accountable.
We must also encourage our governments
and ensure that at the local,
state and federal level,
our school feeding programs
prioritize healthy food,
our public procurement programs
and collectively, we ensure that we keep
the standards high for everybody,
every child.
If you are as impatient as me,
you must also set standards
and hold those in your spheres
of influence accountable
for delivering unhealthy food
for the most vulnerable.
Third, we must support
small- and medium-sized enterprises.
In the food ecosystem,
small- and medium-sized enterprises
are the bedrock of our economy.
They create jobs, they are innovative,
and they can pivot very quickly.
But during the pandemic,
we've seen something.
They are most affected by shocks.
The mortality rates of small-
and medium-sized enterprises
in the food ecosystem has been quite high.
Now through my work,
I’ve seen the value and the power
of small- and medium-sized enterprises.
I'm the co-founder
of a food company called AACE Foods.
Over 50 percent of our staff are women.
Fifty percent of our board are women.
And we produce healthy food,
sourced from over 10,000 farmers.
Through this company,
we're demonstrating
that when you empower women,
you empower communities.
One product that we sell has a ripple
effect through the entire ecosystem.
Another company that's worthy
of emulation is Twiga,
using mobile money and cell phones
to connect farmers to urban retailers.
Now their efficiency
and removing the middlemen,
creating shorter value chains,
ensures that not only the farmer benefits,
the retailer benefits,
but the consumer
has access to healthier food.
And finally, I'm most inspired
by these dynamic women entrepreneurs.
Through Nourishing Africa,
I work with enterprises
in 37 African countries
who are scaling sustainable businesses,
building healthy food companies
and demonstrating that strong,
small- and medium-sized enterprises,
committed to sustainable
agriculture and healthy food,
can become change agents.
We need to support our small-
and medium-sized enterprises,
creating an enabling environment for them,
providing catalytic financing,
enabling them to scale,
and supporting women-owned businesses,
especially businesses run by young women.
(Applause)
In the food ecosystem,
we're often told to be patient
when we plant the seed to let it grow.
We're often told
to let the vegetables simmer
so that the juices will flow.
We're told that "ndidiamaka,"
patience is a virtue.
But a wise woman once said,
"For the dreamer, impatience is a virtue."
I am impatient about the current pace
of change in the food ecosystem.
And I think we all must be courageous
and bold to transform this landscape.
The next time you eat a meal,
ask yourself a few questions.
Who grew this food?
Where was it grown?
When was it grown?
How many steps and stops did it make
before it got to your table?
How much food waste was generated
because of this meal?
Let your answers influence your next meal.
The fact that you have a choice
gives you privilege
and also gives you a voice
to demand that the solutions
to the food ecosystem
align with what works
for people and planet.
We must collectively create
a food ecosystem
that works not just for us
but for future generations.
Our children and grandchildren
will hold us accountable
for what we chose to do today
to transform the food ecosystem.
Thank you so much.
(Applause)